all right we've got a lot to talk about
too because there are a lot of changes
in the eight day forecast what's going
to change for our tuesday now is
temperatures are going to go up a little
more and winds are going to start to
increase through the afternoon beautiful
skies this morning nice and clear winds
aren't too
much of an issue this morning at all in
fact we're not feeling much of any wind
except up in the mountains the spring
mountains getting just some little
breezes southwest breezes will increase
a little through the morning and then
they'll turn to the northwest later
today lots of 60's mainly around the las
vegas valley this morning but things are
going to change or we're going to have a
couple of big heat ups and just in time
for the warmer weather clark county has
decided to open the splash pads at
county parks so this is great news
parents if you're looking for a place to
cool off with the kids as we get into
these hotter april days a little ahead
of schedule but wow it's a great place
to cool off you take the kids to the
splash pads they are free open to the
public and they will last now into
october so it's nice to have those cool
wet places to cool off with the kiddos
and i know you parents run through those
water parks yourself those splash pads
don't you alright so we are still
getting a taste of winter over the
northern plains and around the rockies
but unfortunately severe weather is now
rolling through the gulf coast states
look at these thunderstorms tornado
watch boxes even a couple of areas of
warnings for tornadoes in the deep south
now mississippi to alabama and the rain
stretches all the way up to the
mid-south in the tennessee valley this
morning unfortunately spring-like
weather turning very severe there the
spring weather i should say the cold
front that's heading our way is what's
going to churn up the wind for us and
that will turn
very strong tomorrow in fact with low
humidity and high gusty winds national
weather service has issued fire weather
warnings now all along the colorado
river valley for tomorrow 10 a.m to 7
p.m and wind advisories for the lakes
where we could get choppy waters we
could get waves on the lakes one to two
feet so this could be dangerous and
please take that into account for your
wednesday today we start to feel some
breezes and later in the day as that a
cold front gets closer those winds will
turn from the west to the northwest but
we're looking for 90 degrees today a
little breezy overnight those stronger
winds coming on wednesday as those winds
funnel along the colorado river valley
but we do drop to the low 80s and then
another ridge builds quickly to drive
our temperatures to the highest we've
seen of the year so far in the mid 90s
on saturday our normal high should be in
the mid 70s but then another really
unusually cool late season system will
bring us right back to the 70s on monday
and maybe even 60s
on tuesday so